the taliban are on the march and gaining
territory
at an astonishing rate
we've been invited to meet them inside
their own base they want to show us
as foreign journalists how strong they
are and also how they're in no mood to
compromise
the departure of the bulk of the
american and other nato forces has
emboldened them and they smell
victory one commander in warduk province
told me they would never work alongside
the other groups in government
as a real afghan we would never do that
because they are the people who are
killing and kidnapping
who are thieves and who are corrupt so
we'll never work with them
we're the first foreign journalists to
see the latest army base the taliban
have captured in the province
and they want to show us the treasure
trove of military riches they've seized
with it
many of these boxes supplied by the
americans hadn't even been opened before
the taliban got hold of them
can anyone believe that the taliban
wants peace when you've you've got all
these weapons now
most of the time we don't rely on all of
this we just rely on allah
but it does help us a lot and it's given
us a lot of new weapons we can use in
battle
of course we want peace more people want
peace here but the government doesn't
want peace with us
from this base alone the taliban say
they seized about
900 guns 30 humvees
and 20 army pickup trucks
it's a whole pile of of destroyed
vehicles military vehicles there and a
huge
area that they've managed to take over
i think this the taliban will see this
and view this as a substantial victory
and it follows a nationwide pattern of
afghan soldiers putting up
only a half-hearted fight many of the
fighters we saw were carrying new
weapons
seized during the taking of the base
the white flag that signifies the
taliban takeover is flying in large
swathes of the country right now
and they're creeping closer to the
capital
our journey on route to the taliban was
halted this is a crucial
highway which the taliban have been
trying to get control of
the afghan army brought in
reinforcements to push them back but the
fact that the taliban have got so close
to
the capital yeah they're
making gains
the taliban are winning the propaganda
war able to plant
and detonate roadside bombs with few
reassurances from the government about
how they're going to regain
control instead in taliban controlled
areas
they blame the afghan national army for
injuries and insecurity
we saw no women at all out in public
although the taliban insist they've
progressed
and want their girls educated do you all
welcome the taliban being here
because it's so much safer now the
taliban have brought us security and
peace he says
the taliban paint themselves as deeply
religious
and say they're fighting for an islamic
emirate based on a strict interpretation
of sharia law
like so many others this former prisoner
jailed by the americans immediately
rejoined
the fight on his release
the only thing that will persuade me to
put down my gun is if there's islamic
law here
based entirely on islam and the
government is run according to islamic
rules
the taliban resurgence appears to have
real momentum and that's worrying for
the afghan government and its
international allies
who are now watching all the military
hardware they handed over
ending up in the hands of the group
they're meant to be used against
the government is seen as weak and
deeply unpopular in areas
particularly where the taliban have
managed to take a hold
can you work with any of them they are
nothing anything
you're nothing and this we will destroy
three
we all we are going to
uh destroy our country
they they come they bring
bad bad situation for afghans
for our people for our civilized
for our country for our schools
for our hospitals everything they
destroyed
and this while peace talks are meant to
be ongoing and all the while the taliban
seem to be growing stronger
and that will surely lessen their desire
to do any deals